[Music]
Hello, welcome to Chat in the Arena, the
weekly podcast where we recommend and
exchange ideas about content we've
read, listened to, and watched, always bringing
product and PR discussion perspectives. I'm Artur, there's a
holiday coming up, and I'm... And have you
realized it's the last holiday
weekday of the year? Damn, Moque was happy
and now
you... I'm... I'm... Bad energies, right? Damn,
really? You have to see, I sent 300
things to him and he responded, just ruining
my dreams in all of them. Damn, this
topic here... I sent him a link, damn,
let's talk about this... he's blah blah blah... boom, yes, no, no, no problem,
I said, damn,
man, it's difficult... The worst part is that today I
'm not even... I'm low energy, I'm not spaced out
or anything, just imagine you... I have to
put up with it, it's
true, but in today's program we're
going to talk about the following
topics: What to do when you lack time
to consume things, content and
such, and a news roundup from around the world...
and you know what I was thinking?
Before we get to the little plug, it's just that
this program is very special and
you're ahead of your time because
your parents named you AX,
so it's the only program that has someone
with "A" in their name who talks about "A"—it's
true, I thought you were going to say it's
similar to "X" or that it's an
inverted "X," but it could be,
so there you go, it was less creative than
I imagined you'd be. See? Okay,
let's talk about our plug of the
week, shall we? So, you already
know, right? There's a course coming up at the end of
June, there will be an online course on
critical and analytical thinking with
Dudu and me. We already talked about
it in the last episode, the people
praising the course said, "Wow, I didn't even
know I needed to take this
course until I did it! It's so good that it
took up a whole episode, right?"
Exactly. And so, if you still have
doubts, watch the previous episode
where we talked a lot more about it.
But then, on June 29th there will be
another live online edition and on July
6th in person here in São Paulo.  Paulo, there at the
Arena practice house in Juus. And besides,
on July 20th, which is also a
Saturday, there's another edition of the
AI ​​course for
PMs with me and Efren, and our
A will be there too, talking about the
GPT he created. Now everything makes sense,
you can do the GPTs and everything else
because you speak the language, not only the language
but the name, your name is already... you are the
promised AI,
what's the Dune one? Have you seen Dune
and L? No, I've already fallen asleep 10 times trying to
watch it, but Dune is always cool, D
isn't cool, it isn't cool, but anyway,
the link with the discount is in the description
and we'll see you there. Don't wait until
the last minute to buy, you'll
buy the last batch which will be more
expensive, even though we're already warning you
in advance here, right? Take advantage to
pay less now and with the
podcast discount in the description. That's it, now let's go
PR paa. Let's go
[Music]
Well, the last few weeks have been kind of
tough here at the Arena
Corporation and podcast, right? I think
both  Both of us have been more
caught up in work, and
consequently, this impacts
our pace of consuming content and
things we bring to the podcast, right? And
then I was thinking, why not
make lemonade out of lemons and
turn this into content? Because it
's very common in our daily lives in
production to feel overwhelmed
with work, with all the demands and
meetings we normally have, and
sometimes without even realizing it, we
end up neglecting or even
not wanting to consume
things outside of work hours because we feel it's
work. But it's the kind of thing that, if
you let it, slips away, and when you realize it, you're
not doing it, right? So I wanted to start
this topic by asking you, my dear
co-host, what you do or what
you prioritize consuming in those
moments when you're most rushed and
overwhelmed in your daily life. That's a great question,
but one of the things I think the
first thing is, since you mentioned it, "It's been a
while since I said this famous phrase,
I'll say it here," which is "work, work,
work," but it doesn't mean... don't
forget that the commas represent
pauses. Have you tried that?  I guessed before
you were going to say it just so I could show you how well
I know you, huh? Well, today you're overestimating me, huh?
Underestimating me today,
there you go, uh.
But let's go, man. I think the first
thing, we've already talked about
this a few times, we've already received
this feedback too, like, we're
content-consuming machines, right? We
consume a lot of content, I do
n't know how much is good or bad, but it's
a reality, this is with
counterfactuals, not arguments, right?
Exactly, exactly. But there's a good side to it,
you're tuned in, knowing
what's going on. And when we talk
about consuming content, it's not just
product content, right? It's content of all
kinds, which
may or may not be related to products.
But, man,
one of the things
I do a lot when the
pace is really hectic is what I do
n't give up on, like, I don't give up on
doing my exercises. I mean,
sometimes I do, but I try to
maintain my sanity by exercising.
So it's something I developed
thanks to you, including before
I couldn't do it.  Good for your life,
man, it's more or less, right? Before,
for example, I couldn't run while
listening to podcasts; nowadays
I can barely run while listening to music, you know?
So this is something that really
changed my mindset. I end up
using those moments, for example,
these last few weeks I've been very busy,
but man, I keep listening to my
podcasts. I'm using SPE more than ever,
which I've already mentioned, several
episodes about it, with content
that makes more sense to me, that I
want to read, I don't want to leave it for
later. So that's it. So, I
listen to two podcasts quite a lot, well,
three daily. One is
Denils, which is 15 minutes, there's
Morning Brill Daily too, which is the
news from abroad and stuff, I listen to
Tech Crunch and Stretch Cherry. Those are
the four that I consume, which
are shorter and that I consume daily.
And that's it, I wake up
having coffee and I listen to them, or
when I'm exercising here, I
listen while running and stuff. So I think...  That's
one thing, and another is that
quick glance at emails, even
newsletters, you know, the kind you follow,
save what makes
sense in your pocket to read later
calmly, but it's the kind of thing I usually
do so I don't become
totally oblivious. But again, it
depends on the
moment. There are times when I'm completely disconnected,
and that's it,
especially during vacations, I even uninstall emails and
stuff, like Slack, so I uninstall it
and say, 'I'm going offline, I want to wander
through the world.' It's
curious, this disconnecting thing, isn't it?
And what you said at the
beginning about how we need to be
productive all the time, how much that means,
because I feel that sometimes. Like, sometimes
I have Sunday mornings, a
time I like to read, you know, things
I saved during the week for
later, or longer newsletters, and then sometimes, damn, I
have a commitment Sunday
morning or something like that, I can't
do it, and then I get mad thinking, 'Damn, I did
n't read it, I missed out on
consuming that stuff.' So  There's a
bit of that, but then I think
another thing comes into play, which for me is a bit about the
enjoyment of consuming these things that I do
n't feel are work. And I feel, and
I've talked to several people who
have this "oh, but work is
work content," I don't know what, and I legitimately—and I'm
not saying that people have to
be like me, no, I'm just saying
how I feel, okay? I enjoy following
these business technology things
as a whole. So you said, "Oh, on
vacation sometimes I disconnect,"
I, on the contrary, the time I have
free is like vacation time, things like that, man, it's
the time I'm going to dive into things, I'm
going to read things in more depth,
I'm going to continue following the day-to-
day because I really enjoy it. I think it's
natural here, but again, I don't think
everyone has to be like that, but I think
it helps when it's something you
enjoy. It's
that cliché phrase, but
work with what you love,
who would have thought I'd be saying that? Who would have thought
the Disney link... the Disney link phrase of the
week... let's go, pause PR... the
Disney link phrase of the week: Work with what
you love and consume.  The content isn't going to
be about consuming content, it's not
going to be
work, oh my
God, I'm going to take my
anti-capitalist card
soon, but apart from that, I think I
have a very similar routine to yours,
man, in that sense. Even in
these weeks when I'm screwed, there are things
I don't give up and that I fit in.
So there are a few
daily newsletters that I'll open, I
'll find a space in my schedule, and
normally it's the morning time, I
reserve half an hour, 40 minutes
for L-mail. This
also goes for newsletter emails, which I think even
overlaps with what you said, Morning Brew,
you listen to the podcast, I consume the
newsletter. For me, it works better to
consume the newsletter, but
this is even a
change in behavior, a
change in media, you consume the
content of a specific brand, or a
specific blog, etc. I also
used to consume both The Issues and Morning
Brew, I consumed the newsletter fervently, it
was the first thing I looked at
when I woke up, and so on. Now it
's the opposite, I barely read the
newsletter, it's just the podcast.  I listen to the
podcasts of both of them, and that's it. There's
one that I saw, like
Street Cherry, Street Cherry, the
same thing, Street Cherry. It's tough because
the texts are dense, right? They're long,
dense texts, like that. And then I... well,
because... you can consume it easily, you
know? It's a diary, besides
Morning Brew, there are two Brazilian ones that I
always read too, which are more
business-oriented in general, which are New Feed and
Brasil Journal. Brasil Journal is also very
good. Although I
have ideological disagreements with the
content of Brasil Journal a lot,
sometimes I think they are good
business content, it serves to give me an
overview. And since Boom Ji started... I
also have some
newsletters that I follow that are daily,
but I feel like I open them every day.
At least it's Ben Bites, and I think it
even changed its name to Neuron or something like that,
but it's my go-to
newsletter to find out the news of the
day and new products. And then I have... Tell me, tell me...
no, I was going to talk about another one.
Something I do, which we've even
talked about in previous episodes, is that
sometimes when things are really hectic, I have
my Instagram profile dedicated solely to
tech-related things that I follow. It helps, you know? It helps
because I take a look, whether it's first thing in the
morning or afternoon, that time when
you wake up and want to take a
quick look, you know? I go there and use
Twitter. The algorithm is so crazy that
you can't know if you'll see the
things you want to know. In
general, Twitter used to be my go-
to place for this kind of thing, but
nowadays what I
do with Twitter is I have
my list there. I always do
this: the people I start following, etc., who
I see have cool content, I
add them to that list. So sometimes
I wake up, and the routine is like this:
I go to pray, and you're busy, right?
I go there, look at my tweets, I take a
look at the main news, I take
a look at my list of people
I follow on Twitter too, so I
only see their tweets, and that's
it.  Okay, so... you're doing a
news roundup, which we'll be doing soon too.
But besides the daily ones, there are
some that I look at but couldn't
read during the day, but I'll definitely read them at the end of the
week when I have time.
So, that's it for me.
I know I'll have to dedicate some
time to reading them, because sometimes I won't be
able to during the week, but on the
weekend I'll read
Benedict Evans' newsletter. It's the same thing. So, just a
few that I have that I couldn't manage
during the day, but I'll
set aside time for. And speaking of podcasts,
for me, they're a
lifesaver because, like
you said, I try not to give up my
exercise routine. And I tell
everyone this: I go to the gym
to listen to podcasts, so I don't
fall behind on my podcast list.
And when things are a little
more hectic, when I feel like they're piling up,
I speed up to listen at
1.5 or 2, depending on the
podcast, and fit them into my routine, into
small things like that. So...  I'm going to
wash the dishes, 15 minutes, while I'm
washing the dishes I'll listen to something, I'll
stop for a snack here, then I'll put it on to
listen to something, so I also fit that in, and there's something
you
taught me when we worked together
years ago, you see, I only bring good things
to your life, man. The first thing I
feel here that was good,
no joke, but I don't know if you still
do this today, but you had... You
worked with Pomodoro, if I'm not
mistaken, and in your
Pomodoro break you would open Pocket,
read something, and it would
send articles and stuff to the company's channels, you know? And
I try to do that
too, sometimes in the little spaces in my
schedule, sometimes there are 15 minutes between
meetings, there's like a chat there
to answer anything, so I open
Pocket, I open my
newsletter, I'll read something
quickly, so I fit those in
throughout the day when I can, which
is sometimes better than scrolling through my
Twitter feed or
TikTok, I think.  These are the things
I do, very similar to ours, that
's it.
If you do something
different, send it to us, that's it. If you
have any recommendations, too. I
read this newsletter every day, these
daily podcasts here, so send them to
us too so we can get to know them, listen to them, try them
out.
[Music]
Okay, and in segment two, if you're busy
like we've been in the last few
weeks, we're going to give a
news roundup of what happened last week and at the
beginning of this week. We're
recording on Monday, even though the
podcast will air on Wednesday, the day before a
holiday, but we're going to give a
news roundup of what's happening in the
world of [unclear - possibly "above"]. Oh, well, the most
recent news is that X is going to raise [unclear - possibly "the
opposite"], it's going to
raise 6 billion. That's right, 6
billion is the size of the round, not the
exact valuation, with a PR of 18
billion. That's all, man. I can't put it in words, it's
something beyond any value for me,
so just take it. X, which is
Elon Musk's [unclear - possibly "chat PT"], to
simplify, has Grock, which is
the name of their [unclear - possibly "above"], they're doing a
round raising [unclear - possibly "above"].  Six
billion from the main
investment funds and PR reference, right? Open,
the estimate is that its valuation is
80 billion. And speaking of 80 billion, a company that
has hundreds of thousands of users has
a product that generates revenue,
obviously they are still operating at a loss,
but they have a product that's on
everyone's lips, right? And then you think, "Damn, is
Xai really worth that percentage of
Open?" What's going on there? They're
worth 20-25% of Open, you know?
So what's the thesis? What's behind all this
to justify
this size of investment? Because
in terms of testing and so on, even though they've
launched several things since November,
for example, those
Hallucination reviews, Grock even outperformed
Hallucination more than the
other players, right? So
what's behind this? It
's the ecosystem of Ex and El Musk from
all over the world, because for those who don't know, El
Musk is also one of the founders of
Open, one of the
initial investors in the idea, exactly. And man, I don't
know.  Like, I don't see anyone seriously
using Grock or talking about it
as a real competitor to the
big LLM models, and I'm even
thinking, "I don't know, Grock could be
trained on Twitter data, right?"
And Twitter might eventually license
that to anyone. That's exclusivity,
but I don't know if you're following,
Google started releasing AI previews in
the United States and worldwide, and
people are bringing up some absurd things,
especially things
correlated with answers given on
Reddit, right?
And if on Reddit the
trained answers with Reddit posts are already
generating this kind of thing, imagine
on Twitter, which is the... I'm not proud of it,
but it's the LXR of the digital world,
right? I've been there for a year, but that's it, man, it's
crazy,
so I do
n't know what to think. I can only
think that money is always
there, right? For those who can
convince people well, because that's all
we have in terms of news, there's
nothing more to say about Grock, about
Grock. So let's see what's coming next.
Speaking a little about
OpenAI too, last week a
lot happened and more
people left their Safety team. They
even disbanded one of their
teams, and so on. I
thought the
reaction from people was a bit over the top because, like, the
Safety leader left, and it was a
team dedicated to that. But from the
news, obviously, what comes out in the
press, the company controls it, but it
seems more like a restructuring. It's
not that the Safety team ended, it's that
now they're incorporating the Safety people
or the Safety demands into other teams.
Obviously, they might not have the same weight or
resources. They dedicated 20%
of their processing power to
that team, which is a lot if you
consider that people are fighting over GPUs
in the world.
So still, I don't know, I didn't
find it as bizarre as many people
made it seem on the internet. And
two more things: they finally
made the partnership with Reddit official,
so OpenAI will train the
models on Reddit. In addition, OpenAI
will become an ads partner.  From
Reddit, there's a bit of a commotion going on
because Open... it can't
stay like this... it's a mess, you know? There's no way... the same
company... it's
because Sama... he has a
percentage of Reddit, right? He has a lot... it
was because he was from IC. So they're already
talking about conflict of interest,
damn it! But Sama... he's in all of them,
he doesn't have... it
's bizarre. I've seen the companies he has a stake in, like
Vale, you know?
So the guy
literally... he is the human conflict of
interest, there's not much to
do in that sense. And I think the
last thing that ended up being
available last week is the
GPT chat app, now it's available for Mac
too,
and I'm using it, I'm liking it. Important, right?
It's only for Macs with Apple Silicon chips, right?
And I even researched why,
because my Mac here at work isn't
Apple Silicon, it's an Intel. And they
said, I don't remember if it was in the chat, on the
Open forum, or on Reddit, someone from the
company said it's because they're going to use
exclusive features that are only
available on Apple chips. Most
likely the neural processors,
right? The NPUs?  So what's there might have something to
do with
that, they're not going to have a version for
Max Intel in the future, and then I think another
controversy that happened was about the R ladder,
I was going to f  Okay, so this happened, right? So it
started with people saying, "Hey
guys, there was a mix-up, and you
thought our demo here, the
voice features, were going to be available as soon as it was over. It won't be
yet,
we're going to roll it out gradually." So they
had to say that on Twitter. And then,
a week or two later,
Scarlett Johansson apparently
sued OpenAI, right? Apparently,
she had conversations with Sam
Altman, who wanted to use her voice in the
demo and for GPT chat, for all the
voice features, and she didn't give up
her voice. Interestingly, the voice used
sounds a lot like Scarlett
Johansson's. It's a copy, but not an exact copy, as
someone once said. Exactly, right?
Nothing is created, everything is transformed, as they
say. So there was that, let's
see what happens next week, what the
new OpenAI complications will be.
And I think to wrap things up,
we also had the Microsoft event
last week, which we didn't
comment on. Microsoft Build was very
focused on AI, even though it was a
hardware launch event.
They launched the new Surface notebooks and
talked a lot about it.
So I think the main thing is that
CoPilot+ PCs, which are Windows PCs with
specs focused on having
functionality, need to have CoPilot
integrated. So I thought that was really cool
because it sets the standard for the models, right?
I think something that applies to both
Windows and Android is that,
being a licensed system, you have
many different specs and it's difficult to
develop there. So the PCs that will
have the CoPilot+ seal need to
have at least 250 GB of SSD, 16 GB of
RAM, and 40 teraflops of NPU, which are the
Artificial Intelligence processing units. For
comparison, the most recent MacBook Airs
with PM3s have 18, right? So
a higher processing capacity is expected.
I was even thinking, and
connecting this to the second point,
they presented CoPilot
integrated into Windows, so it sees
everything you do and can
remember the steps you took.
There was even some buzz
related to privacy about this, and it's
totally similar to what...  OpenAI
showed in their Mac app that it's an
app that's always with you and
that you can interact with, so I was
thinking about how not having an OpenAI chat app
for Windows isn't kind of a
non-compete clause, in a way.
So, like, we have a period of time
to get CoPilot running and then
you release the Windows app to
avoid cannibalization, you know? Or maybe it
's a white label, right? Something like that, the
engine behind it is the same
in theory, right? It's the OpenAI models, the
interface changes, but the engine itself is
the same, only here it will
be the pretty face of the integrated
CoPilot, and let's make
an application there, because they like apps,
right? Apple likes them, so we make them for them, for example.
But I think, like the
Google event, Microsoft has dozens of
apps and services where they can add
CoPilot, and they did several
demos during the build about it,
so I'm anxious to use it and see
more functionality of CoPilot integrated into the OS.
I think it has potential,
we who pass it on...  I've been on the
computer all day, working on it,
and there's this thing open that,
if you don't overuse the computer, can
serve as a real assistant. I think it's going to
be really cool. I don't know how
your experience using
GPT chat on your Mac has been. Well, I'm finding it
useful, but there's one thing
bothering me because they have a shortcut to
launch it, to ask
questions, you know? And then it pauses the
onboarding. It's really good when
you install the app. It's really cool when
you install it. The first thing
it shows
you is this thing to activate it. They even give it a name, which is
the launcher shortcut. Uh-huh. And then, just like that,
what can GPT chat do?
And when you press enter, it already appears on the
screen for you to press enter. So,
the experience is really cool. And I'm
using the screenshots a lot, it's been
working and all that, so it's been
like I already used it a lot. For me, it's
more practical because now it's
already on my screen, I don't need to open the
browser, I don't need to keep
switching tabs, you know?  I also think it's
annoying, man, this is being... it's reducing
Pass and improving my
experience, so that's it. I keep
thinking if it's meant to be a kind of
assistant-like use, you know? You're
looking at... I commented
last week that they made improvements to the
data analysis part, and this week
I did a better test, I did
an analysis with them, and I keep
imagining how much more fluid this could
be, like you looking at a table and
actually talking to the GPT chat
while it does that analysis, you know?
It shows the graph instead of
you typing what you want, you
say, "Damn, now drill down on this,
damn, show me this now," over
time, categorize it like that. It's
like you actually have an assistant
doing things for you there, right? And I
think it goes very much in line with what
we've already indicated in this text here,
talking about how
we're going to move more and more from knowledge workers
to location workers, where we'll have to
learn to better allocate the
Agents in each of the actions and who does
what. So I think it's a...  I'm moving
towards that, you know? So, let's see
what else we have, right? Next week,
and that's it, every week a big, big new thing
is
[Music].
That's it, and let's go to our product blog
this week. Let's go. Last week I
started... So, here's number 10, mine is
Meg, the L bank app, which
we talked about last week.
But man, I really, my
use case for it is being my second
bank, but it's solely and
exclusively because of the ease
of fewer clicks that I need to
give, for example, PS, I sent
some money there, PR, so when I
need to make these PIX payments, like this
weekend I was in Santa Rita do Passa, testing,
right? Testing, and also to test, of course,
but I was there in Santa Rita do Passa, which is
a city, you know, the city of Mozão, and there was a
kermess there. And so, to
buy the bingo chips during the Jina festival,
I had to pay, I did
n't have physical money, I had to
pay with PIX, but if I had to
open it, look how many...  How many
interactions are there? You have to
unlock your phone, open the
bank app, enter your password
on the home screen (probably), then
enter the password, go to
the Pix item, type the Pix code or click
to read the QR code, confirm, enter
your password again, and then show the
screen. That's it! If it's been a while,
man, it's wonderful. You go there, take
the photo, go straight to WhatsApp, boom, you
make the Pix payment. For this place,
it hasn't optimized yet, but it just
started, so we'll give it a
pass. But it's not very
optimized there; reading the images
takes a little while, but it's much
faster than all the other clicks
I would need to make. But it's working
very well, it's very practical. Anyway, it's not a big deal, but
I want to see... Remember I was approved
here, and I had to send the document
to continue the flow, and I didn't
continue. I need to go back there, you see? It's a rip-off, you know?
But one thing I was
talking about, including with
Pilon and Lucas, is
competitive advantage because, in the end, they
are, very superficially speaking,
but there are a lot of APIs, right?  That's the kind of thing
banks already have, they just don't have the
WhatsApp interface, right? How
long until the apps, the banks, if this is
really something, if
this movement will make the banks do this
too? And how much of a difference would that be?
But anyway, I'm using it, I recommend it, and you, man, I'm
going to talk about Duolingo here. I
don't remember if I've already talked about Duolingo,
but I certainly have,
but I'm going to bring it up for a
special reason because today I'm
completing 1000 days of streak on
Duolingo, damn, reaching a milestone
here in the use of the app. I already, I already talked about it,
because we commented here about
sending me the Duolingo plushie, and
I'm reaching 1000 days, and the other day there was
a discussion on
Twitter about how
effective it is to learn a language on Duolingo,
how much is it just
entertainment and stuff, and man, if it's
entertainment, at least it's
entertainment that I'm learning some
things,
learning a little French there. The other day
I had to read something in
French at work, it was a paragraph,
I managed to read the whole thing, and
I thought, damn, cool.  A while
ago I wouldn't have had the slightest idea what's
written here, so even if it's just a
joke, I feel like I'm
learning something. So, don't
stop using Duolingo because
you think, "Oh, it's not the most
effective way to learn," because
you're going to learn something, man. So, come see, this is what
the guys sent
us this week. Today my
whole team sent things. I hope
you didn't have to deal with all the
information. I won't,
but first, a
shout-out to the team. Miram sent the
Fifth Floor app, Karina
sent Splitwise (it's been a while since
Splitwise appeared, right?). It
's definitely in the top five most mentioned here, exactly.
Kau, the new member of the
team, sent Mox Stopper, which is a Mic PR app for, I don't know,
doing what on
Mic, in the card game, that same game.
I have some friends who are
Mic nerds to this day, because Neui, who is one
of our devises at Dock, also
sent Chat PT and said he's using it a
lot. And the other Tech Lead, right?
Neu is a Tech app, and the other one is the one Lady
sent, Technofit Box, which is her
CrossFit app, and she's all about CrossFit, she
participated in a championship the other day, a
shout out to NAD, she came in sixth place,
and Lucas, he's been sending this for three weeks,
but he sends it in 300
different places and he's not seen, he's not
read, and he's not remembered anywhere, so when
I try to put it here in the center, I ca
n't, but he sent
SwiftKey, which is the
Microsoft keyboard, right? Oh, Microsoft Swift, exactly,
and anyway, the older products I
use because I think on my
first
Android, a Nexus 4 in
2012, I think something like that, I already used
Swift, then Microsoft bought it, but
at the time it was very different, I think
every keyboard nowadays already has that,
but it had key suggestions, which
wasn't the thing that existed at the time, it
had the thing of typing
by sliding your finger, which wasn't sliding, wow, that was
cooler, wasn't it?
Exactly, so it was an
innovative thing. Then everyone...
Copied nowadays, I don't know if there's
anything innovative, but when I get a new cell phone,
one of the first things I
install is Swifty. That's it, I'll keep
sending you the music apps,
and with that, we end
today's program. Well, that's it, another
week, another little program on
the air for you guys to listen to, the day before the
holiday, on the holiday, after the holiday, and
I hope you not only listen but also
share it, send it to a
friend, if you think
someone might enjoy this program, if
someone you know who's struggling and can't keep
up with the news,
tell them, "Hey, the guys made a summary of what
happened." Give
this segment a listen, the person likes it,
and tell us where you're
listening to the podcast in these last few
weeks. We've already had people say they were
listening while riding their bike,
some said they'll listen while
exercising at the gym,
their workout, and you guys send it, tag us there,
post it there, paid workout paid podcast
check, exactly, exactly, no, it doesn't matter where
you listen, it can be...  On Spotify, on YouTube,
on
Substack, anywhere you
listen to podcasts, that's awesome, right?
Listen to
podcasts, dude! We
'll be there, ready to
receive your podcasts, that's it. So, after
the holiday next week... Rest up,
enjoy the holiday, and
next week we'll be back! And next week there will
be news! Stay tuned, here's
the teaser to see if you
'll listen next week or not, but there
will be news to shake
things up, shake things up, change the
world of
podcasts! Exactly, that's it, so thanks, thanks!